okay i am back for another video i'm
still stalling and doing more concepts
until about june first-ish but uh today
is actually a pretty important topic
which is going to be apache spark so
let's go ahead and talk about that
okay so spark what is it spark is
basically another um open source batch
processing framework that was invented
by a bunch of researchers at uc berkeley
i think around 10 years ago it's an
example of a data flow engine and it is
capable of providing major performance
increases over something that is a more
naive implementation of batch processing
like mapreduce so let's go ahead and
talk about how it's able to do this and
explain all of that
so what are the problems of mapreduce
this is kind of like a throwback to an
older video if you recall mapreduce is
really bad for iterative jobs or any
jobs that are chaining together a bunch
of map and reduces uh for example
pagerank so you know if you're if you're
iterating over some for loop and
basically making adjustments
to i don't know maybe a set of nodes in
a graph or anything like that mapreduce
is really poor for that so why is this
well for starters mapreduce materializes
intermediary state what that means is
that you're doing a ton of disk reads
and writes every single time that you do
an actual mapreduce job because both
inputs and outputs of mapreduce are all
going to be written to the underlying
file store which means that you're doing
tons of writes to the disk and the truth
is the majority of the time we don't
really care about the intermediate
rights we just care about the end result
in addition to that
generally speaking when we're doing
mapreduce the first time mappers are
useful but after that generally we only
care about reducing the thing is though
that we have all these unnecessary sorts
and kind of re-partitions and a lot of
the time it's not necessary and it just
wastes a ton of computation so spark
provides us with a lot more flexibility
by just allowing you to define operators
and give you a more free form just you
know write some code and we're going to
make it happen in a paralyzed type of
way
but let's go into some more detail
so like i mentioned the big issue with
mapreduce was manifesting this
intermediate state and so what spark
chooses to do instead is implement
something called rdds or resilient
distributed data sets so basically these
are just going to be in memory data
structures where their lineage is
tracked and they represent the contents
of some spark variable so that variable
is originally probably going to be
gotten from hdfs or whatever the
underlying data store is and then you
can do transformations on an rdd in
order to go ahead and derive other rdds
so by going and mapping out this data
flow we're able to actually get a really
efficient system going where the
majority of the data is actually kept in
memory assuming they can fit there and
then that way we don't have to go ahead
and materialize everything
so
let's talk about fault tolerance because
basically what i base i just said is
that spark does a bunch of computations
but it goes ahead and just keeps them in
memory and so the kind of the important
thing here though is if things are being
kept in memory and we're running these
huge computations aren't nodes going to
be failing all the time and then losing
that data
so yes nodes are going to be failing all
the time and losing data but spark kind
of uses
these dependencies or the
the graph of lineages for each rdd in
order to kind of make good decisions
about fault tolerance and how to handle
things so generally speaking what spark
tends to do is instead of storing all of
the computation at every single step in
a persistent manner it stores
computation sometimes and then goes
ahead and recomputes it when need be so
let's look at two situations basically
of failures where spark has to go ahead
and recompute data
so the first one is called a narrow
dependency so imagine we have these
three nodes right here and the first
thing that i'm going to do is basically
just a map job we've got all this data
for
browser history partitioned by the date
that it actually happened and the only
thing i'm first going to do is go ahead
and map that browser data from
you know url date tuple to just the url
so
that's just going to be called the
narrow dependency the reason for this is
that there's no inter
node communication the node is doing all
this computation locally only for the
data that it's storing in its actual
underlying hard drive
so
now imagine if node 3 were to fail
so basically what would happen is that
if node 3 failed we know that node 1 and
node 2 can basically just take some
extra load from what should have been
node 3's data and then go ahead and
calculate itself the reason for this is
that
node 3 was making those computations
completely independently of what node 1
and node 2 were doing and so as a result
by splitting up node 3's computation
between node 1 and node 2 we're able to
kind of parallelize that fault and go
ahead and quickly recompute it however
this gets a lot more complex when
there's you know greater interleaving
between the actual data dependencies and
we'll see that in the case of something
where we're grouping together by key
so this is known as a wide dependency so
imagine instead of just taking all of
these urls together
and you know removing the dates from
them that in addition we did something
where we grouped by key and put every
you know unique key on a single node so
as you can see we have all three urls
for jordan donald and joe each on a node
and those are each coming from node one
node two and node three and this is a
very common thing that happens in both
mapreduce and just any type of spark job
because generally speaking you want
similar keys together
like i said this is known as a wide
dependency so imagine the case where
node 3 actually fails here this is going
to be a little bit tougher to recover
from for the following reason
so if node 3 fails we see that the final
state of node three was basically all
these urls for joe
and so in order to go ahead and
recompute all of that we can't actually
go ahead and just basically say
okay let's go ahead and parallelize the
computation of node three over the
remaining nodes that are still alive in
the cluster the reason for this being
that we still have all this over the
network communication that needs to
happen in order to end up materializing
that final state so simply parallelizing
things isn't going to work you basically
have to go back from the start and just
recompute everything before that wide
dependency and then go ahead and do the
wide dependency again so this is really
inefficient when this happens when
there's a wide dependency and it kind of
begs the question okay okay well how can
we you know do better here and actually
make it such that um you know we don't
have to go ahead and recompute
everything
well the answer to this is basically
checkpointing i've mentioned
checkpointing in the past but all it
really does is take you know the given
state of a system and go ahead and save
that to some sort of persistent date uh
data store like i don't know hdfs in
this case assuming that's what you're
running spark on
so what we would actually do is you know
assuming node three was still alive and
we had this data at one point where we
have
those final states of node one node two
and node three and we knew that we were
going to be doing more with it but we
didn't want to potentially run the risk
of you know one of these nodes crashing
and then having to recompute everything
all over again what we would do is
actually go ahead and checkpoint the
result of this wide dependency or this
join and as a result of that if node 3
were to ever crash we could go ahead and
just access hdfs and use that checkpoint
to kind of re-establish a new node
that's taking over the data of what node
three had and then that way we're able
to kind of quickly recover from that
fault as opposed to having to recompute
every single thing
so this is kind of how spark tends to
suggest that you handle wide
dependencies and for narrow dependencies
like i mentioned it's not really a huge
deal if one node fails because you can
go ahead and parallelize all that
computation over the other nodes but
generally speaking for handling wide
dependencies you want to be
checkpointing
okay so in conclusion basically spark is
able to provide huge performance gains
over mapreduce by declining to
materialize intermediate state every
single time there's an operation
and by doing so there are some slight
trade-offs in the sense that spark is
going to be more expensive by making you
use more ram because you're storing all
these rdds in memory and in addition
there is going to be slightly worse
fault tolerance recall that mapreduce
was kind of actually built to be super
fault tolerant because google was
constantly preempting those jobs that
being said it's pretty clear i guess in
industry that spark is much more widely
used these days and i would imagine
that's probably just because of the huge
speed increases that it leads to
so as a result guys i hope you
understand now a little bit more about
these dataflow engines and kind of the
motivation behind using spark over
something like mapreduce in practice a
lot of these batch jobs are literally
gigantic and have tons of data and you
have to chain together a ton of
functions and so mapreduce becomes
pretty infeasible all of those disk
rights just don't make sense
okay so i hope you guys enjoyed this
video i'll be uh hopefully doing another
one tomorrow